hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV I'm in
Las Vegas for freedom fest and I a
monarchy with the arm bro of the Iran
Institute who is the author of new book
free market revolution how Iran's ideas
can end big government thank you very
much for joining us how can they end a
big government well this is an
ideological battle fundamentally about
ideas and what we try to show in the
book is that it's not the traditional
ideas that are going to win this battle
big government grows no matter you have
Democrats no matter if you have
Republicans even if good Republicans
so-called right even 10 diggin couldn't
stop the growth of government what is
needed is a fundamental intellectual
revolution and I'm and identified and we
identified the coal ideas that need to
be challenged actually mall ethical
ideas people don't vote their pocketbook
people vote what they think is right
they want to be good they want to be
good people so we need we need a mall
revolution in this country and in and
that's how we get a free market
revolution now are you talking in terms
of sort of moral defense of capitalism
or as a moral defense of a small to
government what are you talking it's
it's really a mall defense of
individualism and I think the challenge
we face in the world around us is that
the traditional morality that we all
grow up with that we're all taught that
is tweets by everybody in the culture
left right and center is a morality that
I believe is incompatible with
individualism and therefore incompatible
with limited government capitalism it's
a reality up your your brother's keeper
it's a morality of your more
responsibility in life as to others that
is the primary responsibilities
therefore in a deep sense your life is
not yours to live your life is
ultimately owned by other people your
responsibilities towards others not to
what self we need to demolish that idea
we need to destroy that it didn't
replace it with rands view that your
life is yours to live as you see fit
Molly yours to live and it's your moral
responsibility Jamal sponsibility deliv
you're like the best life that it can be
and if we're going to win if we're going
to win the battle for limited government
we have to win the mall argument and
that's where I think we're losing
of libertarianism is most potent kind of
cultural attackers thinking of people
like Curt Anderson who just had a piece
in The New York Times for David Brooks
they will argue with at least some merit
on the underlying facts that we have
more individualism in this country than
ever before individuals have more
autonomy over their own lives thanks to
the internet and thanks for a lot of
other things and that's the problem
we're all too individualistic or to a
demise as a society and what we need to
do is find a way to come together how do
you square your analysis not just with
their critique which one can disagree
with but also with the ideas that it is
true I think on some level that we do
have more control of our individual
lines and have a more individualistic
eat those perhaps in the way that we
govern ourselves well there's a certain
element of truth there so it is true
that because we're wealthier we have
more choices I mean money does buy
choices money does in a sense buy
happiness because it provides with
choices if you think about a subsistent
farmer it's not a lot to present a lot
of happiness the pursued a all you do is
work and you you barely survive at the
same time we've always also constrained
our freedoms dramatically so those
choices are consequences of wealth that
came from freedom what we're doing now
is constraining that freedom so that we
can create that well so we won't have
these choices in the future and at the
same time they are certain choices we
don't have that we used to have it's
very difficult to start a business in
the United States day suddenly a lot
more difficult than it was a hundred
years ago right that's a choice that's
gone the fewer entrepreneurs today than
we would have if we had no regulatory
environment indeed in my view we would
be so much more wealthier today the
other thing that they ignores is the
question of what is freedom at you mean
you know the question of freedom from
what right because you're free what does
it mean in my view is freedom is freedom
from coercion government is the biggest
violator of our rights today so while
they've kept us free from coercion of a
neighbor they caused us significantly
and a dad coercion is limiting our
choices limiting our freedom limiting
them other wealth and their mouth
technology and the matter
good stuff that we can create and just
it has profound psychological impact so
this is not just a materialistic issue
this is an issue of self-esteem this is
an issue of spiritual values that we do
not have we can't attain that
self-esteem because we can't do the
things that we have the potential to do
because we're restricted by government
to do it and I think the biggest victims
here are not the wealthy so oh the
middle class so much as the ambitious
poor what people who institutionalized
into poverty because of the entitlement
state poor people are institutionalized
into poverty because the regulatory
state because they cannot own take
control over their own lives it can't go
out there and make a living you know my
favorite example is minimum wage how
many poor teenagers are with keeping out
of the workforce because of minimum wage
and therefore they will never build up
skills they will never build up
self-esteem and therefore they will
never be happy seems at least in the
casual observer that Iran's been much
much more juice since let's say
September of 2008 are you optimistic
about her growing influence do you their
reason to believe that these ideas are
taking more of a route than they were
previously just to give you a number
since Obama was elected Atlas Shrugged
is sold 1.5 million copies that is a big
big number so yes I think I think there
is really a lot of good signs out there
is a lot more taking iron man seriously
both from opposition and from our
friends I think that the Tea Party
movement is one of the most positive
phenomenas in modern American history it
is a movement that has come out of this
emotion of enough's enough we be
trampled on enough stop it they don't
quite know yet what to do about it they
don't quite understand what freedom
means and what it requires they don't
have the intellectual ammunition to win
but that's our role our job is to bring
them that intellectual ammunition
there's no question in my mind that Iran
in spite a large extent inspired a
movement in our victory the female good
movement victory is going to be
when when we can embrace Iran's ideas
and when enough people out there in the
culture embraced those ideas and that
fundamental note thank you very much
your own book really appreciate it
4recent TV I am Matt Welch